Uruguay es un país famoso por su selección
de futbol.
De hecho, ahora que se celebra el Mundial
de Fútbol en Rusia, hemos repasado el palmarés
y resulta que sólo hay 8 países que han
ganado la copa del mundo alguna vez. Uruguay,
con sólo 3 millones de habitantes, es uno
de ellos.
Y además, en ambos casos, fueron victorias
contra dos países con los que comparte frontera:
Brasil y Argentina
Y precisamente de eso vamos a hablar en el
vídeo de hoy, de cómo Uruguay ha conseguido
superar a sus vecinos. Aunque no, no vamos
a hablar de fútbol. Vamos a hablar de economía.
Porque, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
Uruguay es uno de los países más ricos de
Latinoamérica, al menos en Renta per cápita.
También uno de los más estables y con mejores
servicios públicos. Y en la que a política
se refiere, Uruguay tampoco se queda atrás
¿Os acordáis de su expresidente, José Mújica?
Se trata d e la gran rock star de la izquierda
no sólo latinoamericana sino mundial. Más
conocido como “el presidente más pobre
del mundo”.
Sin embargo, mientras Mújica vivía con tan
poco dinero, su país crecía, atraía a empresas
extranjeras y se convertía en un pionero
en avances sociales. Con Mújica en el poder,
Uruguay aprobó el matrimonio homosexual.
Pero, sin duda alguna, su medida más conocida
fue la legalización de la venta de marihuana.
Mucho antes que California o cualquier otro
país, Uruguay fue el primer país del mundo
en permitir el comercio de cannabis para uso
recreativo.
¡Pero no sólo eso! Veréis, si hacemos una
foto fija de Uruguay, podríamos decir que
es el mejor país para vivir de todo Latinoamérica.
A diferencia de Brasil y Argentina, que son
sus vecinos, Uruguay no ha dejado de crecer
económicamente desde el año 2002. Tiene
una clase media pujante. Y los sueldos más
altos de toda Latinoamérica, compitiendo
mano a mano con Chile.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no todo es
tan bonito! En realidad, para ser un país
tan próspero, llama la atención que apenas
es capaz de atraer a inmigrantes ¡Y no es
porque tengan unas leyes de inmigración especialmente
duras! Lo cierto es que muy poquita gente
elije vivir en este país. Y la razón es
que, en los últimos años, las cosas se están
empezando a torcer en este país.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué la economía
de Uruguay ha funcionado hasta ahora? ¿Qué
méritos le tenemos que achacar a José Mújica?
¿Y cuáles son esos nubarrones que acabamos
de mencionar? Hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia.
LA SUIZA DE AMÉRICA
Uruguay nació en el año 1830 tras una guerra
entre Brasil y Argentina. A los británicos,
que fueron los que negociaron la paz, les
interesaba que Uruguay fuera independiente.
El puerto de Montevideo era una auténtica
joya y no querían que cayera en manos de
ninguno de los dos grandes países.
¿Y quiénes vivían en Uruguay? Pues, prácticamente,
nadie. Había una tribu, los llamados CHARRÚAS,
pero eran muy pocos y en seguida fueron exterminados.
Y por eso, a diferencia de otros países latinoamericanos,
casi todos los uruguayos son de origen europeo.
Más concretamente, españoles e Italianos.
Por aquellos años, si eras un chico con ambiciones,
Uruguay era el sitio donde emigrar. A la misma
altura que Estados Unidos o Argentina. Una
democracia moderna y con estado de derecho.
Los datos no engañan: en un país con buenas
condiciones de vida y ajenos a grandes conflictos,
la población pasó de un millón en 1900,
a 2 millones a mediados de siglo y 3 millones
y medio en la actualidad. Un crecimiento de
la población muy lento si se compara con
otros países de la región.
Al igual que sus vecinos de Argentina, Uruguay
era un país muy rico. De hecho, hasta los
años 60 estaban muy por encima de España
y muchos otros países europeos.
Así que ahora os preguntaréis ¿En qué
momento cambió todo para Uruguay? Porque
una cosa está clara, aunque sean una de las
economías más prósperas de Latinoamérica,
están lejos del nivel de vida de casi cualquier
país Europeo ¿Qué ocurrió, entonces?
Pues la respuesta está en la Comunidad Económica
Europea, lo que luego sería la Unión Europea
¡Tal cual como lo oís! Y es que, mis queridos
amigos de VisualPolitik, si pensábais que
eso de las guerras comerciales es un invento
de Donald Trump, estáis muy, pero que muy,
equivocados.
Con la creación, en 1958, del Mercado Común,
Europa se cerró en banda para las carnes
uruguayas. Así que el único amigo rico que
le quedaba a este país era Estados Unidos.
Pero en plena guerra fría, el tío Sam tampoco
tenía mucho interés en hacer acuerdos comerciales
con Uruguay. Bastante tenían con lidiar con
otros países más problemáticos.
Así que, de un día para otro, la economía
uruguaya se estancó. Y en Montevideo no les
quedó otra que empezar a mirar más a sus
vecinos. Especialmente a Argentina, que se
convirtió en el principal destino de las
exportaciones. De repente, Uruguay se convirtió
en el Robert Rodriguez de Quentin Tarantino
¿Qué Argentina tenía una crisis? ¡Uruguay
también! ¿Qué Argentina tenía una dictadura
militar? ¡Uruguay también! ¿Qué Argentina
tenía una democracia?¡URUGUAY TAMBIÉN!*
Y, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik ¿Qué
ocurrió en Argentina en el año 2002? ¡Exacto!
El famoso “corralito”. Una de las mayores
catástrofes financieras de la historia. Para
que os hagáis una idea, en 2002, el PIB uruguayo
cae un 7,7%. Una auténtica calamidad de proporciones
nachovidalianas. Y ese fue el momento en el
que Uruguay se dio cuenta de que tenía que
cambiar de socios comerciales ¿Pero cómo
se puede hacer eso? ¡Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver!
EL KILÓMETRO 0 DE AMÉRICA LATINA
En los años 80, los primeros gobiernos democráticos
de Uruguay hicieron una cosa muy interesante:
sentar las bases legales para el desarrollo
de las zonas francas. Y os preguntaréis,
¿Qué son estas zonas francas? Pues no son
más que territorios donde el Gobierno ha
decretado que no se pagan impuestos nacionales.
Ni el IVA, ni el impuesto de la renta, ni
impuesto de sociedades. La única exigencia
es que el 75% del empleo tiene que ir destinado
a la población local
¿Os suena de algo?
Sí, es como las zonas económicas especiales
que tanto les gustan a los chinos. Pero esta
vez, creadas al 100% por uruguayos.
Uruguay tiene 11 zonas francas. Y las hay
de tres tipos. En primer lugar, las orientadas
a la logística y el comercio exterior. En
segundo lugar, las que sirven de base a multinacionales
para prestar su servicio en toda Latinoamérica.
Y finalmente, las zonas especialmente preparadas
para la industria. Eso explica que Uruguay
esté tan avanzado en cosas como la investigación
farmacéutica o el software.
¡Pero aquí no termina la cosa! Estas zonas
francas tienen una ventaja única. Algo que
hace de Uruguay un país modélico. Estamos
hablando de la ESTABILIDAD POLÍTICA ¿Creéis
que es una tontería? Pues… nada de eso.
En el año 2005 Uruguay tuvo un cambio de
gobierno. Pasaron de tener un presidente de
centro derecha a uno de centro izquierda.
En este caso, hablamos de Tabaré Vázquez,
del Frente Amplio. En otros países, esto
podría significar el fin de estas zonas francas
¿Verdad? ¡Pues nada de eso! Si algo caracteriza
a Uruguay es el consenso entre partidos.
Eso explica que, entre el año 2005 y 2014,
la inversión acumulada en las zonas francas
llegó a casi 6000 millones de dólares. Y
todo esto mientras Tabaré Vazquez primero
y José Mújica después, gobernaban el país.
“En el mundo no solo se busca ganancia.
Se busca también seguir dad. Y eso lo ofrece
el Uruguay. No es un problema de este Gobierno,
ni del otro. Es una actitud de los uruguayos”
Y ahora os preguntaréis ¿Cuál es el beneficio
que saca Uruguay de las zonas francas no pagan
impuestos? Pues, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
el beneficio es doble. Por un lado, se establecen
en Uruguay industrias que en igualdad de condiciones
buscarían otros mercados con mayor número
de consumidores. Y estas grandes empresas
extranjeras necesitan proveedores. Así que,
en seguida surgen pequeñas empresas locales
a su alrededor. Y, por supuesto, los empleos
que se generan son cualificados y con buenos
sueldos. Es decir, que los uruguayos no tienen
que emigrar para encontrar un trabajo.
Pero… ¿Y todo esto qué tiene que ver con
cambiar de socios comerciales? ¡Pues mucho!
Porque gracias a estas zonas francas, Uruguay
pudo dejar de producir, únicamente, carne
y soja, para empezar a vender productos de
valor añadido.
Por ejemplo, ahora mismo, Uruguay hace los
concentrados de PEPSI para toda Latinoamérica.
Es más, hay una bebida que triunfa en Japón:
la Pepsi Azuki. Se hace a partir de un vegetal
que es el HABA DULCE. Pues bien, el jarabe
para hacer esta bebida se fabrica a 200 kilómetros
de Montevideo. Para que os hagáis una idea,
la PEPSI supone el 7% de las exportaciones
de Uruguay.
Pero hay más casos: una de las principales
papeleras del mundo, la finlandesa UPM tiene
una de sus principales plantas de producción
en Uruguay. Y, según han dicho, van a construir
otra planta más que podría suponer un 2,5%
más de PIB para el país.
¡Pero esperad porque todavía hay más!
En Uruguay también tenemos otros sectores como
el del software.
Ocho desarrolladoras de apps uruguayas, entre
las mejores de América Latina
En definitiva, más del 30% de las exportaciones
de Uruguay se hacen ya desde las zonas francas
¿Y a que no adivináis quién es el principal
comprador de los productos Uruguayos?
¡Una pista! Empieza por CHI y acaba por NA. Para
que os hagáis una idea, Brasil y Argentina
han pasado ya a ser sólo un 20% de las exportaciones
de este país.
Otro gran amigo de Uruguay es Holanda. El
puerto de Rotterdam es el punto de entrada
a Europa. Y buena parte de las exportaciones
uruguayas se dirigen hacia allá.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a diferencia
de Chile, que es el país más rico de la
región, Uruguay está muchísimo más diversificada.
En Chile, la mitad de sus exportaciones dependen
del cobre. En Uruguay, sin embargo, hay muchísimos
sectores interesantes. Hemos hablado de los
refrescos, el papel, el software y, por supuesto,
la carne y la agricultora… ¡Sin embargo!
¡Esperad un momento porque las cosas podrían
torcerse mucho antes de lo que pensamos!
UN GOBIERNO FRENTE A SU PROPIO PARTIDO
Desde el año 2005, la izquierda gobierna
en Uruguay con un partido que se llama el
Frente Amplio. Y lo cierto es que hace honor
a su nombre. Se trata de un partido tan amplio,
que hay toda clase de sensibilidades políticas
y no ganan para discusiones.
El primer presidente frenteamplista que tuvo
Uruguay fue Tabaré Vázquez. Después, como
los mandatos no pueden prorrogarse, le sucedió
José Mújica, esa rock star de la izquierda.
Luego, volvimos a tener a Tabaré Vazquez
de nuevo. Tres cambios de presidente pero,
sin embargo, hay algo que no cambia: el ministro
de economía, DANILO ASTORI. Quedaos con su
nombre porque es muy importante.
Sin embargo, pese a todo ese consenso del
que hablábamos antes… el Frente Amplio
es de todo menos tranquilo. Dentro del propio
partido hay un ala radical y otra más moderada,
que sería la que representan VÁZQUEZ y ASTORI.
MÚJICA estaría entre medias. Y eso explica
que, cada vez que el Gobierno ha propuesto
un tratado de libre comercio con otro país,
se ha encontrado con la oposición frontal
del ala más radical del partido.
Pasó en el primer gobierno de Vazquez, cuando
intentó firmar un acuerdo con Estados Unidos.
Ha pasado hace poco tiempo cuando el nuevo
gobierno de Vazquez ha querido firmar un tratado
con Chile. Y podría ocurrir de nuevo, pero
esta vez con China.
“En el año 2018 cumpliremos 30 años de
relaciones diplomáticas. Y hemos fijado esa
fecha como límite para firmar el tratado
de libre comercio”
El objetivo del Gobierno es evitar a las empresas
uruguayas aranceles anuales en China de más
de 100 millones de dólares. Sin embargo,
dentro del Frente Amplio, parecen tener alergia
a la palabra “libre comercio”. Y, por
si esto fuera poco, muchos compañeros de
partido critican a DANILO ASTORI por que dicen
que gasta poco.
Pero, precisamente, ese es uno de los grandes
problemas de Uruguay: el gasto público. Después
de Venezuela, Uruguay es el país con mayor
porcentaje de funcionarios. 1 de cada 5 empleados
trabaja directamente para el estado. Si a
eso le sumamos el peso brutal de la economía
sumergida, tenemos que sólo la tercera parte
de los uruguayos en edad de trabajar lo hacen
en el mercado privado. En la mayor parte de
os países desarrollados, esta cifra es de
más de la mitad.
Por supuesto que, comparado con Argentina
o Brasil, Uruguay es un auténtico paraíso.
Pero lo cierto es que, si quiere seguir creciendo,
tendrá que atajar estos problemas lo antes
posible.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que Uruguay
tendría que aprobar esos acuerdos de libre
comercio? Si tuvierais que vivir en América
Latina y pudierais elegir un país, ¿os decantaríais
por Uruguay?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto!